xavier schmitt soeur jean jacques guéry
notre correspondant à bruxelles nous le
disait cela peut prendre beaucoup de
temps plusieurs années pour une adhésion
de l'ukraine à l'union européenne
effectivement on a des exemples à la
chute du bloc soviétique on parle là il
ya trente ans beaucoup de pays de ce
bloc ex-soviétiques donc ont soumis leur
demande d'adhésion aux alentours de 1995
ils sont entrés dans l'union européenne
en 2004 dans le cadre d'un élargissement
alors pourquoi parce que les critères
jean-jacques ans en parler les critères
pour adhérer à l'union européenne sont
assez long il ya déjà pas cette
procédure d'urgence évoqué par le
président zelensky hier elle n'existe
pas même si selon ses termes elle est
juste et elle est possible le fait
qu'elle soit juste on l'a vu tout à
l'heure au parlement personne ne l'a
remis en cause le prime c'est que le
processus est très long on l'a vue donc
pour les autres pays issus du bloc
soviétique et bien ça a pu prendre neuf
ans les pays du balkan eux-mêmes sont
déjà toujours candidat j'ai envie de
dire il ya cinq pays qui attendent
encore à la porte de l'union européenne
tout simplement parce que eh bien il
faut déjà se mettre en accord avec se
rapprocher de la législation du pays à
celle de l'union européenne du droit
européen ça ça peut prendre un peu de
temps et puis les critères sont assez
variés les critères politiques l'état de
droit une démocratie stable et la
protection des minorités ça c'est le
premier élément ça touche au à l'article
49 du traité de l'union européenne c'est
sans doute pour cela que le président
heynckes qui a voulu notamment rappelé
bien que le peuple ukrainien se bat
actuellement pour les droits de l'homme
et pour la liberté c'est un rappel qui
était assez judicieux que les critères
économiques sont également présents une
économie de marché viable une capacité à
assumer certaines obligations notamment
la concurrence au sein de l'union c'est
que jusqu'ici et bien au delà des
soubresauts historique de l'union avec
notamment une parenthèse de présidence
ukrainienne particulièrement russophone
qui avait repoussé
l'idée de l'adhésion et bien je
régulièrement l'idée de l'adhésion
ukrainienne elle bloque sur un point
c'est la corruption qui est qualifié d'
endémique par l'union européenne et la
cour des comptes européenne de lieux a
remis en septembre dernier d'ailleurs un
rapport spécial une enquête spéciale
autour de la situation en ukraine
rappelant qu' il y avait des efforts
qu'ils avaient été réalisés mais qu'à ce
niveau là au niveau de la corruption il
y avait encore énormément d'efforts à
faire les autres critères et bien c'est
notamment
souscrire aux objectifs de l'union
européenne et notamment de l'union
politique économique et monétaire ça ça
peut quelquefois poser problème et puis
ça a été glissé lors de la réunion de
copenhague dans les années 90 en 93
avant justement l'adhésion des pays du
bloc soviétique
il faut aussi
prendre en compte la capacité
d'absorption de l'union européenne par
le passé certains pays les pays
occidentaux notamment considéré que à 27
eh bien on avait voulu grossir trop vite
et que ça ne permettait pas à l'union
européenne et bien deux d'avancé
suffisamment dans de bonnes conditions
dirait ton ces critères-là ils seront
forcément mises en avant par les pays
dits occidentaux par les frigos qui eux
vont mettre le critère économique sans
doute en avant par certains pays
également qui
savent que vladimir poutine pourrait
l'utiliser à des fins d'attac également
contre d'autres pays de l'est on sait
que actuellement des pays issus du bloc
soviétique en tout cas de l'ex bloc
soviétique membre de l'union européenne
soutiennent cette demande d'adhésion à
rapide immédiate de la part de l'ukraine
on pense à la tchéquie on pense à la
slovaquie notamment mais pas la hongrie
qui a toujours jusqu'ici refusé cette
adhésion ukrainienne justement notamment
pour des raisons
géo politique vis-à-vis de la russie
merci xavier